e arrivata l'ora di fare finalmente
unito su smash dopo sei anni di youtube
o forse no ho fatto uno comunque ragazzi
siccome io non gioco smash consenso non
ho ancora avuto modo di approcciarmi
nella direzione di smash o invece un
sacco di amici che hanno perso famiglie
relazioni perché giocano un sacco quindi
oggi sfiderò i miei amici e smash
partiamo da dei livelli di difficoltà
partendo dal più difficile al più
semplice visto che faremo una partita
con ognuno e ognuno d oro mi spaccai
partiamo col primo livello 1 seppure
spaventato
era la comparsa ok adesso solo per voi
quindi per tantissime persone
la sigla di smash corso musicale
particolarissimo immagino ma il 3
convegno introdotto come il livello 1 in
realtà sei molto più nel senso di
belluno di difficoltà massima voleva
scalare i livelli sono livello 0,50 di
molto vivo i nove capito tutto io sono
0,0 e qualcosa per farci lei che non gay
perfetto allora senza t'interessa la
cuffia io voglio sentire il rumore della
mia morte l'olio già non va il mio
joystiq che è una cosa veramente
fantastica allora ragazzi io sono a
destra e lui a sinistra proprio come
nella webcam pini perfetto però è che
kirby è stato deciso da zero
si è il più scarso il beige a e proprio
è stato dichiarato va bene una partita
già in una partita dei batteri se io ne
vinco una in questi tre match che oggi
sono bravissimo porco schifo
[Musica]
no no sempre di genere ricavo tanto cosa
vuol dire vista la mostrerò molto specie
adesso che la nostra sbloccata e non è
che sopravvivere che quelle mosse ciò
nella mia testa non è che 98 gente l'è
fatta una 6 gol che può essere quello si
potrebbe essere validati si pedala
[Musica]
mi sa che questa forse non la vinco però
se il livello più difficile mi consolo
almeno un proprio fatto almeno a cento
dai io perché di vento che adesso è
diventato il possibile di zelda se si
portò cavallo misto diceva no dai a meno
che non diventi un oggetto
dipendentemente da il tizio che ci
accordi ma potrebbe essere si no
niente vi ho detto nel momento più
doloroso disturbarsi l'ha ringraziata
rigiocata può essere ma io puntavo a
questo voglio siamo riusciti
nell'intento la ringrazio torni a
trovarci quando tempo per lo meno
difficile di mare il livello 1 l'abbiamo
fatto livello 2 che però è in difficoltà
inferiore teoricamente pratica allora
per la morto sul colpo
guardo ok sa perché non parlo perché dio
faccio parlare i falliti quindi essere
state sfidando tutti me ma vi insultate
vita tra di voi che non c'entrate niente
i ragazzi scelgo sempre kirby così
almeno avete un punto di riferimento su
chi sono io sono vi confondete
giustamente atto io solo volevo salutare
ed è un parolone saper usare poi è bene
mangiare
è un appello per la brace lei anch'io a
dire mai ma sono già andata meglio che
tuo fratello siamo pari io so solo
trasformino oggetti guardare vabbè vabbè
ma dai ma perché è perché se il
prevedibile prepara di loro mi sto
veramente impegnando ci sono buchi sta
intrattenendo a bra o no o trattate no
non è che saras tra prevedibile ma dai
ti sei quadrato la sola vincenzo
tonnellate non mi puoi far niente come
lo è soltanto quello dipende molto da
stormi consenso poi vorrei lasciarlo a
scoprire un mondo normale ma non può
farti netto tanto la bravata
incredibile la prima kilda partita cioè
della del video marco l'hanno uccisa
neanche una volta si parlava di me
si è scelto dalle dr.sse tua ecco perché
la maggioranza prepara di preparati
quando già contento così
[Musica]
no cristo aic perché perché perché è una
palla sovietico di berlina bar di questo
no
la donna che prugna tso fortissimo però
bravo mi chiedo però alla provare libro
questa è la fine no dai
ero andato a tanto così cavolo si
complimenta di complimento il convento
io è stato molto bravo marco che mi ha
temperato un pochettino complimenti
ringrazio aver partecipato anche a lei
prossimo nuovo entrato in servizio di
comunque si esce più bravi ragazzi siamo
all'ultimo livello quindi andiamo sempre
un po più sulla mia qualità tecnica di
smash vediamo almeno questa riesca a
vincere già un miglioramento rispetto a
prima
prossimo partecipanti come disse diva di
overwatch siamo al livello di difficoltà
facile se mai lo è io penso che ne conte
ne condiva potrei portarmi a casa per
calo con cicero fatto frigo guarda ai
anche una ancora più così lei dico se
perdo questa me ne vado a casa nelle
lunghe null su 3m il montaggio che sei
sono già a casa ho già a casa quindi
niente cori che sono di caio ha pensato
che fossi tifoso come molto che loro
nido veloce
skopje la metà dei personaggi che sono
invece non sufficienti conosco per
smesso allora lui viene da finance e tu
hai giocato il mazzetto vabbè allora
ascolta miglio non ho idea di quale sia
il suo il tuo asset di mosse
non ho idea di niente di questo gioco so
solo che se non ne vinco neanche una non
smettono di fare ho visto sotto l'albero
dietro 5
ti do un indizio non hanno dato gli
altri quando mi trasformo in 100
tonnellate non c'è un se mi tocchi non
mi fai partire
vogliamo stare così tanto l'albero è lì
che ci riguarda dai fari si dà vita ai a
chi male scherzavo
mamma mia che brutta roba eh vabbè
madonna che brutta roba
mamma mia ragazzi cioè impossibile
veramente stupito fare un sacco di views
e io faccio veramente se mi dispiace
tutti quelli che toccano smash
mi scuso tantissimo io non so fare
niente
però questo lo farai mamma mia che
faccenda brutta se come ciccio si è
tenuto tanto perché certe mano meglio
felicissima
ma tu mi piace quando ti fa sto frame di
un attimo sta fermo e poi fa dovrebbe
fare tagliate male ma niente niente
niente ma devi sapere una cosa che io
parente per cinque mesi sono andato a
vivere a casa di italians trucks a
milano e tyler è uno dei migliori
lucas d'italia quindi io sono dovuto
sorbirmi ogni due sere lui ei suoi amici
tendo 16
razer cioè gente della community
italiana di smash che giocavano a dare a
te io so soltanto ami questa era la
bravo quindi un qualcosina l'ho imparata
non qualcosina e la zona pip fosse
tekken serve tutta un'altra storia e lo
posso sottoposto a secondarie lui sta
dicendo il giusto ieri abbiamo giocato
ma l'altro ieri con negativamente
no no
sono vivo
ho fatto il velino numeri
hotels.com ai gatti almeno almeno però
era combattuta e racconta stata quindi
secondo me è stata come ci sta ragazzi
10 venite abbassatevi livello 1 il
livello 2
chi a livello 1 viola va bene io volevo
dire che ci c'è più forte grazie cosa
porterebbe gli ha tolto quasi 3 e quanto
ha detto succedere
quindi ragazzi spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto ringrazio i ragazzi non hanno
partecipato e ci vediamo al prossimo
video peccato non c'era giampiero sono
era era ancora più ci amici faceva
ancora male a dopo già andrea ciao ciao
amici
[Musica]